but we began with Sky High anger and
frustration of Travelers who are trying
to take a fight anywhere on Southwest
Airlines it canceled more than 2 600
flights yesterday that's two-thirds of
its scheduled routes by comparison Delta
United American and JetBlue had fewer
than 200 cancellations combined
yesterday after frigid weather hit air
travel hard over the Christmas weekend
southwest's CEO says the airline is
doing everything it can to return back
to normal but more cancellations are
coming Transportation secretary Pete
butterjich tells CBS News the government
will hold the airline accountable Tanya
Rivera is at LaGuardia Airport in New
York Tanya good morning
good morning Nate Southwest has canceled
more than 13
000 flights in the past week including
more than 2500 just today all this on
top of an already busy holiday travel
week that is leaving passengers
scrambling
it's just been chaos everything's
canceled and no we can't get through the
Southwest multiple cancellations you
know a night in the airport a night a
Christmas Eve and a random Hotel the
winter storm caused thousands of
cancellations across Airlines but
transportation secretary Pete Buda judge
says southwest's unique inability to
recover goes beyond the storm's Ripple
effects because what we're seeing right
now from the system and the flights
themselves to the inability to reach
anybody on a customer service phone line
it is just completely unacceptable in
his first public comments since the
Meltdown Southwest CEO Bob Jordan
apologized and blamed the weather for
the disruptions we're the largest
airline in 23 of the top 25 travel
markets in the U.S cities where large
numbers of scheduled flights
simultaneously froze as record bitter
cold brought challenges for all Airlines
this storm was forecast for five days
everyone knew
even those not affiliated with Airlines
knew what was coming and Was preparing
Southwest wasn't Captain Casey Murray is
the president of the Southwest Airlines
pilot Association the scheduling
software is which is a large part of the
problem Southwest can't connect
airplanes to crews in his statement
Jordan did acknowledge it was time to
double down on plans to upgrade its
systems for these kinds of circumstances
Southwest shouldn't have been a little
bit more prepared for this and they
weren't but while the airline tries to
reset now thousands of passengers are
still trying to find their way out of
the travel mess I was traveling to be
with a ill family member Kimberly day is
pregnant and traveling with her two
children they've been trying to get from
Phoenix to New York to visit a sick
relative on Tuesday Southwest told them
it cannot rebook their flight until
Saturday I'm just devastated on so many
different levels but we're trying to
keep a positive but it's hard
for travelers stranded right now here
are some tips to help most Airlines will
try to book you on the next available
flight but that doesn't mean they will
check other carriers you are entitled to
a full refund including seat and baggage
fees even if you purchased a
non-refundable ticket and try to look
for flights that leave in the morning or
at night those tend to be the most
reliable Adriana
oh really good to know Tanya thank you